ми з буду вам мама будь шоком
зізналася я потягну підписані без
нашого відома за наші фактично спиною
gets вода baci не збилася чому їх до
800 5 10 5 7 десятих мільйонів гривень
ціни пропустимо і маю че таку
зв'язку з я скакав і ВТБ і 62 процедури
одного заручника та 855 мільйонів на за
милих витрат але ми ми не захочемо ми не
можемо як частими і всього проекту у
людей це у нас буде 50 років і чекаємо до
так званому ти ж євро башта 30 ук
не все достатньо якщо терміни та ми
допомагаємо всі роботі вся чим не стирчать
щорічного дня та максимально жвавою
ефективно проводити переговори
процедура про відкриття процедури
закопували
[музика]